of course nobody wants to go to war
nobody wants to die it's the decision
that ukrainians and our government have
to make or we fight or we talk with
Russia and at the moment nobody wants to
talk with Russia and all the our opinion
pools show that ukrainians are not ready
for any negotiations because we know
what comes after that Russian occupation
and all the horrors that it brings but
at the same time uh there is a big gap
between civilians and soldiers because
civilians were hoping that the war could
be won without them because especially
in the first year of this fullscale
Invasion zansi and our government were
talking that it's going to be the year
of our Victory and it didn't happen and
a lot of PE people feel disappointed
because of that